nous abordons cette cette fin de
chantier comme vous voyez avec le
traitement des abords et notamment donc
ce bassin d'orage qui aussi été très
important dans ce projet parce que
hormis sa nécessité environnementale
aussi c'est une vraie scénographie
d'entrées depuis depuis le sud
parallèlement au nord donc on a un accès
principal des étudiants et des
chercheurs et d'administration qui
arriveront un jour du futur métro aérien
ou pas et rien d'ailleurs c'était un
bâtiment qui a nécessité beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de mises au point une
très grosse synthèse
en effet vous le voyez c'est un bâtiment
totalement métallique qui repose sur un
socle un socle enterré en béton dans
lequel se trouvent les parkings est donc
cet exo structure était très
intéressante là d'un point de vue
environnemental puisque c'est toute la
paix la filière sèche donc l'ensemble du
bâtiment s'est construit comme un
meccano au fur et à mesure donc c'était
extrêmement intéressant même au niveau
de la fabrication et de la mise en
oeuvre de voir cet exosquelette
arachnéen comme ça se monte et ensuite
venir avec des systèmes de plancher qui
était aussi préparé sur place comme ça à
poser au fur et à mesure
aussi soin d'essayer de donc de mettre
en oeuvre et à profit de notre notre
expérience était aussi d'aller jusqu'au
bout de cette démarche environnementale
l'intérieur en termes de second oeuvre
nous avons expérimenté un produit très
intéressant qui est à base de gypse et
qui donc pour le cloisonnement va rester
totalement brut donc absolument pas pas
unie enduits et ce sont simplement des
plaques qui sont vissés et donc ils
reprennent aussi tout ce système vous
voulez de construction et de aussi de
démontabilité possible à travers ce
matériau donc qui est comme des lambris
qui suit parfaitement le module du
bâtiment évidemment on a cherché à que
ce soit le mieux dessiner possible et
puis que ça ait dans une idée d'un
bâtiment léger abstrait et effectivement
on se voyait pas sur ce plateau venir
avec un bâtiment en béton mais on
voulait plutôt rester dans une idée de
transparence de légèreté est rentré en
écho est en résonance avec le paysage